i gave you a good lead in didn't i i'm
gonna tell a different story oh okay
we've done two of the three elements of
a hollywood pitch hook and log line now
we have three act structure can you talk
about that please sure hit it you hit it
no no no
well let's assume
that you're in a meeting
and you get through the
hook
and you get through the log line and now
you're sitting there you're
discussing
you're trying to fill it in and you make
an appointment for
three to four weeks ahead and they ask
you come back with a fully fleshed out
three act structure
you might get lucky and do it that day i
i i rather doubt it
executives are busy
come back
now you've got
the
setup which is the first act
the
the main the conflict which is always in
the second act and then a very short
i think short third acts what we've
found
are the best and that's the resolution
and everything builds just like you know
and i think the great example in the odd
couple is
in the in the film
i forgot how it was done on the stage so
long ago that i saw it but they're on
the roof and
and walter matthau playing oscar
says to felix um
i can't take it anymore i'm going crazy
you gotta go
and and
and and uh jack lemmon says in other
words you're throwing me out and and and
walter matthau says
not in other words those are the perfect
ones
right and now we're in act three because
it's as high as you can go in the
conflict and what happens in the third
act is oh and felix leaves saying where
i go when i do it'll be on your head you
know he puts the curse on him that's the
that's that great detail in the top of
the bottom of the second act
and and then the third act is all about
oscar worrying about where felix is and
if he's okay and
and if you're pitching you don't tell
the ending of the third act and unless
you've sold it
and or they've optioned it and then you
have to work out the full story
it's not an outline
people think it's an outline that comes
later if you're lucky
but it's much more filled in and has
real details
so that we get to know who the
characters are
what peter did which i thought was
really great
um i'd like to take credit for it but i
didn't have anything to do with it is he
said i'll bet you he said to me when we
were writing i don't know the fourth or
fifth draft that we can
make this structure
applicable to anything and he created
three acts as you see in the book
for an app a food app and i would let
him tell you about that because that's
his but what i think what i'm saying is
i think that structure
of rising conflict and resolution are
applicable to anything and what's
important business is just as in drama
you're trying to solve a problem for
somebody
so you know
i gave you a good lead in didn't i i'm
going to tell a different story oh okay
how rude of you
i had this fellow come in
stage fright guy
and
he said
i graduated from stanford i work in an
investment bank
and
every week
i'm giving a new company to research and
i have to present it to the board to see
if they want to invest in it
we have a bunch of venture capitalist
types
and i get so
scared
i'm on the fast track everybody that
does what i do was really smart
graduated from top schools very
competitive
and basically i'm throwing out the
stream of numbers to glazed over eyes
and it's horrible
so i said why don't we try three act
structure here
so act one as jeffrey was saying is the
setup here you get the background of the
company and the major stuff they're
trying to do what their position is etc
act two the really important part where
you set up the conflict
here are the parts
and the structure of the business that
may be a problem that may not here's the
upside here's the downside
and then three the resolution
here's my recommendation
and
the first thing that he noticed was all
of a sudden everybody's sitting forward
listening
and he said the thing that amazed him
the most is he threw out two-thirds of
the numbers because he said if the
number doesn't move the story forward i
don't need it
i just used to regurgitate numbers but
now the numbers are the data carrying
the story
having everything make sense i'm giving
them fewer numbers that are more
important and helping them lead to a
better decision
and so if we don't tell the ending of a
screenplay if we if we leave out the
resolution what are we doing with a
business pitch
again you're doing the same thing you're
sort of leading them to
well here's your upside here's your
downside
but
this is morphing into another area area
we love which is the psychology of
persuasion
because there's interesting
there's a whole field now of behavioral
economics that's come up in the last few
years and one of the things that we know
is when people make decisions
you can make a decision from an
optimistic point of view of look at all
the cool things we
can have happen or
here are the risks do we want to take
the chance so we can have this happen
and the curves are not equal
people are much more risk-averse than
they are optimistic about what could
happen
and so as you're doing your third act
you're thinking in terms of
if i really want to push the company to
do this i have to show a way to lower
a little bit what that risk might be
if i'm wanting him to be really careful
i got to push that up
but i'm hitting a natural tendency to
say
not so fast
okay so this naturally leads to what i
think gets left out of a lot of
business and show business
pitches
a pitch is not a sale
it's a conversation
so what peter's saying is that if you
leave out
some things you leave room for the
imagination and the participation of the
person on the other side of the table
who like peter heller told us manager
peter heller that
they're also human beings and they have
ideas and thoughts and so when you go in
and you start selling somebody and you
say this is it
right away all of us as human beings
stop
whether we say it or we just think it so
really i think one of the things that we
hit very hard about pitching in the book
is
even if you don't sell the product that
day they're gonna remember you
and maybe they'll have something else
that's right for you and they'll call
you back if you're obnoxious and you
insist on everything being
your way
it's not gonna it's not gonna happen and
i think that kind of selling
should be going it should be leaving
because it's jeff jeffries bring up a
really important point it's the first
time for everything
one of the one of the things that
a lot of writers have difficulty with is
receiving notes getting criticisms
having people make suggestions
and it's kind of the hey i'm the writer
you're not you're telling me what to do
what are you trying to say here peter
and
um
the word that you use for people to who
do that really is amateur
because a smart writer
loves it when somebody's making comments
any sort of comments any suggestions
because
that's a sign that you're starting a
creative collaboration with somebody
that they're interested enough
in what you're doing to want to be part
of it
which means they have more buy-in you're
much more likely to get a green light
and so
if you get one of those it's golden and
you want to encourage it
we actually talk about strategies you
can use
if they're not making comments to try
and elicit them
and again you know well you know you've
done a project so and so which we really
loved
based on that how you know what would
you do with the situation with where if
you had a character that was in this
situation so there were ways to elicit
this sort of collaboration
but again the more it's a conversation
in its two way
the better rather than i don't know many
people that that like to be talked at
not counting you two of course sure sure
yeah